maya flores who is the young republican
latina woman who just flipped texas 34
red this is a texas border district that
had been democrat controlled for about a
hundred years and she just won elon musk
who was a recent texas [ __ ] transplant
he actually voted for her
and she did an interview on fox
explaining why she thinks she won
mata president biden won your district
by 13 points in 2020
your husband is a border agent we talk
about the wide open border all the time
is this
the the main issue for the hispanic
voter what can you tell us about the
hispanic voter and uh what you're
expecting in terms of votes come
november
well the main issue is inflation it's
the cost of living everyone is
extremely pissed off angry at the body
administration because of the increase
of gasoline of groceries of medication
that is hurting them tremendously not
only here in south texas but in the
entire country and of course the border
crisis is something that we see here
right behind our backyards it's not
something that we need to be told by the
news it's something that we're seeing
here every single day and me that i came
here when i was six years old i was
blessed to come here legally but i don't
want my experience to be a rare
experience i want more children like
myself to be able to come here to the
united states legally as well and the
bible administration's policies are only
hurting immigrants hurting the american
people and because of him we hadn't we
have an increase of child trafficking in
this country and this is all on the
biden administration and vicente
gonzalez was part of the problem as well
here in south texas
her name by the way is myra not maya so
i apologize because i think she's going
to be a huge political star what's she
basically saying what's she basically
saying a district that went to biden
people are upset about the money
situation people are upset about the
economic situation of course they're
also upset about the border situation
over there they're watching you know
transients and all sorts of illegals
just jump over the border just flood
through the border and take over their
cities and then god only knows where
they go throughout the country but the
point is that that election i think is
going to be a real bellwether for what
happens what should happen uh in these
midterms that enough people are just
like you know what maybe the republicans
aren't all racist
maybe they're not all white supremacists
maybe they're not all homophobes and
bigots and they just don't really want
the government to do that much and
by god uh gosh darn it
uh the government hasn't done a lot of
things well over the last couple years
and i'm gonna vote differently i'm gonna
vote for that white supremacist
republican party
so of course the democrats see this
coming so they need
the virus and why would they need the
virus because the virus of course gets
them to mail in ballots just listen to
joseph r biden back in 2020
it was a lesson in voting amid a virus
long lines and two and a half hour waits
in some places voters and poll workers
wearing masks and protective gear with
plexiglass between them i don't think
people should be voting today people die
democrats want states to expand early
absentee and mail-in voting have all the
experts both political parties and
academia laying out what would take to
have voting by mail i'd much prefer to
have on you know in-person voting but
most republicans including president
trump
don't like the idea no it shouldn't be
mailed in
you should vote at the booth and you
should have voter id
crazy voter id actually showing your
identification when you vote something i
did not have to do when i lived in the
dystopian nightmare of california i
actually showed my id i pulled out my id
to show it to the guy and he kind of
freaked out like no no we don't know
that all you have to say is a name and
an address so if you know your
neighbor's address you can vote as your
neighbor on top of the fact that michael
here who now lives in the free state of
florida and he's got a job and the whole
thing uh he got a mail-in ballot for a
california for the california election
uh just a couple weeks ago while he
lives in miami
you see what's going on here so the more
that they can push you to mail in
ballots the more the shenanigans can
happen and all of those things i'm not
saying that things are fully rigged i'm
just saying you can sort of see the
pieces right it's just about seeing the
pieces that are kind of floating around
right in front of you and that we should
be doing things to secure our elections